sería la clasificación más grande y más
poderosa que el gobierno de Estados
Unidos le puede dar a una organización
de Crimen transnacional Sin embargo la
Casa Blanca ha dicho en ocasiones
anteriores que Designar como terrorista
los carteles mexicanos no le va a dar al
gobierno de Estados Unidos y a la casa
blanca más poder más poder del que ya
tienen para actuar en contra de estas
organizaciones brinquen en esta
audiencia de hoy en el congreso además
agregó que lo que se necesita es más
tecnología en la frontera porque la
mayoría del fentanilo que está entrando
a través de México entra por puertos
legales precisamente brinque también
resaltó que efectivamente hay lugares en
México donde el gobierno de amlo no
tiene control es de Resaltar también que
la Casa Blanca ha dicho que lo que tiene
que empezar a hacer también el gobierno
de biden es trabajar más con el tesoro
con el departamento del tesoro para que
los familiares y amigos de los cárteles
mexicanos no puedan usar la plata Que
les pagan los consumidores acá en
Estados Unidos para ingresarla al
sistema financiero estadounidense
Cristóbal este es solo un capítulo más
en una atención que se viene gestando
hace semanas una que se agrega al
generado por el informe de Derechos
Humanos que publicó esta semana el
departamento de estado sobre México
Cuáles son las denuncias que hace este
informe y Cuáles han sido las reacciones
del gobierno mexicano
una denuncia es bastante fuertes entre
ellas que el oficial es mexicanos están
están haciendo crímenes arbitrarios
torturas están desapareciendo
civiles están
entrando en actos que rayan con los
abusos de derechos humanos y este
reporte precisamente da detalles de este
accionar de oficiales mexicanos en
contra de la población Además del
reporte dice que ha habido impunidad de
la justicia mexicana para responder
frente a estos crímenes y que no es
concretamente Estados Unidos
los que encuentran esta información sino
organizaciones locales en México que han
nutrido al departamento de estado con
esta información para ellos poner y
juntar este reporte que comparten al
respecto el presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador pues ha reaccionado
bastante fuerte diciendo que
Washington en Washington son mentirosos
que siguen aferrados a la doctrina
Monroe que solo ven la paja en el ojo
ajeno Y no el tallo en su propio ojo y
pues además dio un espaldarazo a el
expresidente Donald Trump en el juicio
que pues cruza en este momento acá en
Estados Unidos hablo también reaccionó
en cuanto al tema de El fentanilo y de
las declaraciones de blinken diciendo
que no es en México precisamente donde
están consumiendo el fentanilo